je m'appelle coma brut
j'ai étudié la théologie et je suis
exercice de profession un exorciste
moi l'église une commande de combattre
le mal partout où il se trouve que peut
savoir ce que vous voulez j'ai besoin de
votre aide
n'êtes-vous pas curieux de savoir ce qui
va se passer
cette nuit dans le village de dykan cas
et tous ses environs les femmes seules
relèveront de la promulgation
une disposition spéciale jusqu'ici mes
visions se sont toujours avérées exactes
c'est pour votre vie que je m'inquiète
les esprits malins se déchaînent les
jours de fête ils ne connaissent plus de
limites
ça risque d'être dangereux
c'est une sorcière très puissante
si jamais elle invoque il viendra